jean marc bonjour alors tout d'abord
sera-t-il possible de combler le déficit
public sans procéder à des hausses
d'impôts comme l'affirmé bruno le maire
vous savez je crois que les français ont
le droit d'être sceptique parce que les
sommes en jeu sont colossales
alors bruno le maire parle d'un coût de
crise à 86 milliards + 130 milliards de
prêts qui seraient garanties par l'état
la réalité elle est quand même très
supérieurs si on part du début de la
crise du mois de mars le fameux quoi
qu'il en coûte vous vous en souvenez
lancé par emmanuel macron à la veille du
premier déconfinement et bien doit
couvrir le chômage partiel toutes les
aides aux entreprises le fonds de
solidarité les prêts garantis par
l'étendant à parler et puis toutes les
déductions surtout deux de charge
d'impôts les impayés aussi puisque comme
il n'avait plus d'activité il ya
beaucoup moins d'activité on va perdre à
peu près 11 % du pib sur l'année
ben ya forcément moins de recettes
fiscales moins de charges sociales
l'état a mis le paquet pour éviter que
le système ne s'effondre en bref le plan
de soutien avait déjà mobilisé 450
milliards au début de l'année en mars le
deuxième confinement a nécessité un
déblocage supplémentaire de 20 milliards
il faudra sans doute remettre 20
milliards au pot pour aller jusqu'en
janvier au total ça va quand même
représenté 550 milliards à la fin du
mois de décembre alors tout n'est pas
imputer sur le budget de l'état mais
c'est un peu pareil parce que tout
revient finalement à la charge du
contribuable il ya beaucoup de sécurité
sociale là dedans il ya de la sncf aussi
avec un emprunt important des
collectivités le cadre que cet argent a
été emprunté il a été emprunté le total
de la dette française a explosé tous les
compteurs
on est à plus de 120% du pipe on a
emprunté en france en est on a une masse
de dette en france qui est supérieur à
la richesse que l'on créé 120 % 2700
milliards d'euros c'est gigantesque
alors les taux d'intérêt sont très
faibles et donc cette dette ne coûte pas
cher mais c'est pas une raison
il faudra la rembourser et ça n'est pas
de l'argent magique bruno le maire vie
de réaffirmer qu'il n'y aura pas d'impôt
nouveau on est quand même sceptique mais
pour des raisons plus politiques
qu'économiques je crois qu'on ne peut
pas augmenter les impôts en france avant
deux ou trois ans d'abord parce qu'on va
avoir une échéance présidentielle dans
deux ans parce que les francs la france
est aussi aujourd'hui une des
championnes d'europe des prélèvements
obligatoires la majorité des
contribuables n'en peuvent plus
respectés alors comment va ton affaire
jean marc nom et à quatre raisons
possibles on n'est pas quand même dans
une impasse la première façon possible
serait d'annuler purement et simplement
la dette coville au niveau de la banque
centrale européenne pour tous les pays
européens
c'est une idée qui commence un
circulaire en europe le ministre de
l'économie italienne a d'ailleurs déposé
un projet dans ce sens là le week end
dernier en soirée dessus il faudrait
évidemment un accord de tous les pays
européens c'est un accord politique mais
l'accord politique il est difficile à
obtenir face alors la deuxième phase on
est bien sûr est de faire de l'inflation
tout le monde y pense mais ça ne se
décrète pas de la façon dont elle a fait
beaucoup autrefois de l'appelation
l'inflation c'est quoi passe et une
augmentation un peu artificielle des
prix et des salaires ce qui fait que les
dettes dix minutes valeur est alors le
problème c'est que les six médailles 10
minutes valeur sa ruine ceux qui ont
prêté de l'argent sa ruine les rentiers
c'est très compliqué à faire dans des
démocraties européennes où la majorité
où les majorités sont fait quand même
avec des gens plus âgés que la moyenne
ne voit pas des gens plus âgés que la
moyenne se voter la ruine comme ça la
troisième façon c'est d'espérer qu'il y
ait de la croissance espérée qui est de
la croissance et la thèse de bruno le
maire si ça redémarre si on crée de
l'activité mais y aura de la richesse et
les impôts reviendrons ça demandera du
temps 7 ou 10 ans il faut qu'on règle le
problème du virus mais ça peut
fonctionner ça peut fonctionner sauf que
l'argent emprunté doit être utilisé à
des fins d'investissement si ce n'est
des investissements eh bien ça générera
de la richesse scission des frais de
fonctionnement c'est-à-dire si on paie
des salaires si on paye des subventions
si on pêche
j'allais dire les charges de
fonctionnement quotidienne de ça et ça
ça marchera pas donc la thèse de bercy
c'est qu'il faut
investir énormément d'où le plan de
relance prévus pour 2020 théâtre de
quelque 100 milliards en investissement
transition écologique digitales etc donc
croissance forts mais attention il faut
aussi une majorité politique qui fait
qu'ils veulent de la croissance forts
nous avons en france aujourd'hui des
courants politiques et nos courant
notamment le courant écologique des
verts qui ne sont pas partisans d'une
croissance molle parce que la croiser en
forme et bien c'est beaucoup plus de
consommation d'énergie beaucoup plus de
pollution
merci beaucoup alors pardonnez moi mais
la quatrième la 4e façon si l'on ne veut
pas augmenter les impôts bas ce sera
d'aller chercher de l'argent là où il
est dans les parcs
ja il n'est pas le colossal en france
les pannes des français alors on peut
lancer un grand emprunt
coville à l'échelle européenne sachez
déjà chez en france en 1958
ça marche pas toujours parce que l'union
européenne n'est pas forcément unanimes
sur ce point on peut aussi vendre les
éléments du patrimoine
il ya énormément d'argent les chinois
ont beaucoup d'argent ils sont prêts à
tout acheter tout ce qui se présente sur
le marché ils ont déjà commencé à le
faire
politiquement ce serait quand même la
pire des chemins de la pire des
solutions
merci beaucoup jean marc sylvestre
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes notre
éditorialiste économique